on netflix the romantic period drama
bridgeton
which drops christmas day think downton
abbey meets
desperate housewives and e.t was
exclusively on the set
do not tell me that is yet another
scandal she this one is different this
one
this subject's by name more zing than
downton
it's more outrageous maybe than downton
abbey
more elaborate kind of feisty kind of
daring
modern twist on it i'm tuning in
i'm watching this it doesn't get more
dramatic or dishier
it's a full-on dinner plate lunch plate
and breakfast a dish
nothing but dish yep this is a costume
drama set in 19th century london but
since it comes from the mastermind
behind grey's anatomy shonda rhimes
you know there's romance scandal and
more than a few mcdreamies in this
photogenic diverse cast
as a woman of color how could i not be
thrilled to be working for shonda rhimes
and i'm also thrilled
to say yet you know what people of color
existed in this country right back to
roman times
bridgeton is the name of the ultra posh
family at the center of it all
the lush british locations and sets
definitely take your breath away
hello entertainment tonight this is
jonathan bailey anthony bridgeton in
bridgeton and welcome to the set here in
the uk
and of course this is really similar to
my
house at home as all brits do live in
these sweeping staircase halls
it's very steamy well we we've had an
intimacy
coach which i've never had before on a
job
which is amazing to work with we
rehearse everything almost like a stun
[Music]
this is a very steamy program i know i'm
gonna have to warn my mum before it
comes out i'm like we'll just get you
the censored version
as for the passion well the look is bold
colors and lots of corsets
many of the costumes are one of a kind
created for each actor's body
each flower on here is hand stitched
including the one i'm wearing today
very very beautiful my name is lady
whistle down
you do not know me and never shall and
to recognize that voice
it's the legendary julie andrews who
narrates the sexy series when it
premieres on netflix christmas day
i certainly know you
you